they're not asking for much in fact
these children just want water
journalists are banned from this area
but the person filming these scenes on
the border between belarus and poland
says there are babies as young as two
months old here some families haven't
eaten for several days
at night temperatures drop well below
zero
at least 2 000 people many of them iraqi
kurds are now stuck in makeshift camps
along the razor wire
social media footage from recent days
shows refugees and migrants escorted by
mast belarusian security towards the
border sometimes shots are fired
and people have often been beaten as in
these pictures filmed by polish forces
[Music]
the eu says the government of alexander
lukashenko is playing a dangerous game
in retaliation for sanctions imposed
over human rights violations
for its part russia a traditional backer
of belarus is accusing brussels of being
hypocritical
the situation is indeed very tense and
there's a tendency to escalate tensions
that causes concern it's apparent that a
humanitarian catastrophe is looming
against the background of europeans
reluctance to demonstrate commitment to
their european values
lithuania poland's neighbour and fellow
eu member has now imposed a state of
emergency along its border with belarus
this is the prime minister visiting
border guards on wednesday
in a phone call german chancellor angela
merkel has appealed directly to russian
president vladimir putin to exert his
influence on the regime in minsk
but as governments play the blame game
the humanitarian situation becomes more
dire by the day nadeem baba al-jazeera
the united nations human rights chief
michelle bachelet has called on states
to resolve the migrant crisis in a
statement she said hundreds of men women
and children must not be forced to spend
another night in freezing weather
without adequate shelter foods water and
medical care and under international law
no one should be prevented from seeking
asylum let's get more from dominic kane
he joins us live from berlin and dominic
we are seeing these diplomatic blows
being traded but has there been any
movement in terms of resolving this
crisis
well from the one side of things from
the european union perspective you have
lots of different voices but they all
seem to be pointing in the same
direction if if we can say that that
effectively from the center from
brussels you have people saying we
share the view of the polish government
we want to express our solidarity with
the polish government and so today we
heard from the president of the european
council of ministers
michelle saying that that the
european union can find its way to
helping poland with its infrastructure
at the border which of course
effectively means shoring up that border
we've heard from
the spokesperson for angela merkel that
she spoke to president putin in moscow
and deplored conditions on that border
and referred once again to this concept
of instrumentalization of migrants of
refugees the clear view being
expressed here in berlin but also in
brussels and elsewhere certainly in
mosque in moscow in warsaw pardon me
that the belarusian government is
choosing to use the fate of these
migrants these refugees on their border
as an instrument of their foreign policy
and we know that the belarusian
government says this is absolutely not
the case and that the belarusian
government has identified itself
alongside the russian government in its
argument with the eu so lots of words
being traded lots of angry words being
traded but so far at least no direct
action plan
and dominic what about the people who
there themselves michelle bachely had
obviously called for
foods and water and medical supplies to
get to them but they're still trapped
in
on the border there is there any
movement at all
well they are trapped at that border and
as we've been hearing the night time
temperature is around hovering around
freezing and over the course of the next
few days in the next few weeks as we go
further into the european late autumn
towards winter in that part of the world
it gets increasingly very cold indeed
and stays that way for much of the day
and certainly all night so
it's arduous and then we know that there
are some who've managed to get across
the border to get across into polish
territory well for them then according
to international conventions that's the
first place in the eu that they could
claim asylum but we know the welcome
awaiting them in poland is not as warm
perhaps as the welcome that might await
them here in germany we know that very
many of those who have made that journey
have risked the arduous journey and got
to germany well they try to claim asylum
here we know also that many of the
people who are trying to get across
right now they say they want to get to
germany and the figures back that up
that over the course of the last five
weeks or so on average every week more
than a thousand people have declared
themselves to the german authority
having made precisely the journey that
the people currently at the frontier
want to be making
so
in the short term they have to
deal with the conditions that they are
facing right now those who get through
have to hope that the polish government
will honor international law and and
treat them well but it's not clear at
all what is going to happen the only
thing that's certain is that while there
is uncertainty their situation will stay
as it is
okay that's dominic kane uh reporting
from berlin dominic for now thank you
[Music]